ragazzi no dai ma porca eva lercia no
[Musica]
festivo bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video sono fan di j
siamo in un luogo blog e lo dico in modo
così sciolto perché sto per mostrarvi
una cosa io vivo da solo da circa due
anni come molti di voi sanno io soffro
di aracnofobia perché ero beni fanno
schifo i ragni mi fanno schifo in
generali gli insetti o registrato questa
cosa che è successa ieri sera a casa mia
ed è successo questo guardiamo allora
porco il demonio incastrato in un albero
infernale c'è un [ __ ] insetto
gigantesco che entrato in casa e porca
di una eva è tornato l'incubo degli
insetti stavo giocando a dar stone che
lì per terra quasi dovuto quando qua mi
passa davanti uno schifo in terra che
non avete idea
mamma mia roba ovvero briosa e in tutto
questo devo anche vincere la partita
porca eva è andato qui io non ho visto
dove è andato ma è andato vicino ragazzi
fa veramente schifo era cosa più brutta
che io abbia mai visto
non sembra esserci nora gas l'ho perso
io non dormo più eccolo eccolo che
schifo
madonna ma che cazzo è ma che cazzo oh
mio dio mio dio cosa cazzo è no raga
basta cambio casa no no no ragazzino dai
ma porca eva lercia noi non posso vivere
così dai ragazzi vi giuro
[Musica]
solo la partita mi ha toccato non c'è la
partita è la partita l'ho vinta e
[ __ ]
chi c'è enormi no ragazzi a cosa più io
non ho mai visto in sé tossico ma porca
eva ma dovevano tornare indietro via via
ritorna tra le fiamme dell'inferno merda
me lo metto allora vi facciamo io vi
piaccia la videocamera qua io tento di
spezzarlo fuori mentre che lo spazio
fuori
in teoria se riesco passa di qui passa
di qui e poi lo vedete quanto è grosso
poi non avete idea poi non ce l'avete
enorme figlio di [ __ ] tra i cuori
volta che merda guardi che merda
guarda che è merda che merda cosa cazzo
è cosa cazzo ego la merda
no vai via dal mio cazzo di tornino
mania mi fai schifo dei morire fu morire
male dove cazzo andato via
no reed ricaduta d'attacco neonata mezzo
dal mazzo così no no no non cominciamo è
non cominciamo dalla [ __ ] non
cominciamo
giuro che ero seduto qui e mi è passato
qua e io ho guardato l'inferno è stato
rino ragazzi c'erano al senso di
esistere starò ma poi perché a me porca
eva ma ma io non ho mai visto nella mia
vita un insetto così grosso di labico lo
chiamo mio padre europa arrivava col
fazzoletto e techno andava a prendere io
questo manco col mitra lo tocco ma
neanche col mito che schifo e tornado e
come cazzo entrare in casa mia
raga è tornato non è possibile e allora
[ __ ] se ti dico figlio di [ __ ]
fatti vedere basta fatti vedermi che
tramazzo ve lo giuro ho chiuso la porta
come ha fatto ad entrare continua ad
entrare in casa mia come cazzo fa è un
insetto enorme come far entrare in casa
no è assurdo se si inizia ti schiaccio
proporta ci schiaccia ti schiaccio con
la porta finito che tutto ti schiaccio
tutto ti schiaccia la famiglia non lo
vedo vino avermi se mi mise io posso io
posso fare la stabilità io la posso fare
questa vita io non la posso fare messa
vita volo di fondi rende voi non capite
voi non state capendo quello è satana è
satana degli insetti e satana quella
roba lì
cos'è cose minchia che li lanciò il
pallone me lo tira indietro
cos'è veramente non posso far star
vitaliano veramente gli insetti li odio
li detesto mi fa veramente schifo
allora droga a noi due spero che adesso
prendo questa e minchia neanche massimo
decimo meridio il gladiatore schifo di
uscire da lì guardi rintanato non è il
gretto e temo non usavo per far luce a
esserci in in sé ma quello è
classificato come insetto o come
chihuahua devi uscire da lì porca eva
esci o t'ammazzo esci esci potere che
avevo trovare un modo per tirarlo su
non so come devo trovare un modo per
tirarlo su kibaki dei fan no questo è
troppo piccole ti serve un qualcosa con
cui posso toccarlo almeno da due tre
metri di distanza tipo allora ragazzi
sto improvvisando sto improvvisando
perché non ho altre cose con cui
toccarlo per spostarlo io con questa che
potete vedere quante la distanza non so
se riuscirò a farlo però ci provo se
vedo che si muove scappo muoio sarà
vibrato il telefono [ __ ]
si chiama temi in un momento del genere
porta è una chiamatemi bravi bravi sono
riuscito a tirarlo fuori ragazzi ci ho
messo una vita
pesci dalla mia porta da morto innocente
mai più hai capito è il momento di
assicurarci che non ci segua più
a posto datemi un lanciafiamme cazzo
perché a me è perché ciò che zampe lui
che iscritti o come quello schifoso
poteva apparire in questo video e quindi
mia sgattaiolato in casa grazie era una
seconda una terza evoluzione di qualche
in sé cioè proprio è andato tante
caramelle rare a quello schifo ma se non
fossi stato il setto fobico gli avrei
lanciato la palla avremmo giocato
probabilmente a tedesca come fai con il
tuo migliore amico in cortile kabul
potevano farmi paura non so le ciotole
il colte alla pesca dentro la nato a
pecorina gli porta di una [ __ ] live
ma detto questo ragazzi passiamo ad un
altro punto volevo annunciarvi in questo
blog
ed è una cosa per me per me volta il
motivo di orgoglio
sempre in ambito horror è perché
rispetta roba di prima se non sempre in
ambito horror è uscito il libro di
filenet freddy's wow è uscito davvero lì
non li fai mete freddy's per chi è
praticamente scop scott stockton cauto
perché non ho mai capito come si
pronunciava il creatore di final del
freddo ha fatto il libro di fai da tè
freddi e quindi so che me lo porterebbe
ai raduni perché già firmate due proprio
magari si schifo io ma non l'ho scritto
io find and the flag iss per chi non
conoscesse è quel videogioco horror che
ha spopolato in tutto il mondo è
praticamente in italia nei video che ho
fatto su venete freddi se sono quelli
che hanno raggiunto più visualizzazioni
e quindi la casa editrice del libro che
si chiama che si chiama il il castoro
scusami leo e si chiama castoro c'è
scritto scritto qua e quindi niente la
casa editrice il castoro ha deciso la
mia ha pensato cioè non andare
tra i market o da qualche parte solo che
sono disordinato come lo schifo mandato
una lettera mi ha detto mi ha scritto da
ricordo mi ha scritto che secondo loro
io sono perfetto per lanciare il
l'uscita del libro di aia l'uscita del
libro di fai da te freddy's in italia
perché sono quello che ci ha giocato e
che se l'è goduto di più come gioco sono
goduto un sacco per me comunque libro
potrebbe essere una roba figlia o dieci
anni appena fa buio loro si sveglieranno
gli spiriti degli spiriti dei bambini
morti si leveranno e decideranno tutti è
un libro allegro e quindi grazie
innanzitutto per il libro e soprattutto
grazie perché non ho dormito prima
avendoci giocato sicuramente non dormirò
dopo averlo letto
volete un consiglio visto che questo è
il primo di una trilogia mi pare
aggiungete nei prossimi capitoli find
the fray this nel libro
l'insetto di ieri che siccome c stanze
dato quel tocco di horror in più alla
storia wow
credi ragazzi spero che i loghi oggi vi
sia piaciuto se non credo di poter fare
altro visto che quella roba lì mi ha
traumatizzato come se si riuscirà il
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
come io per la descrizione che qualcuno
mi dica come mai cisti fottuti insetti
continuano a pervadere nella mia vita e
noi ci rivediamo in un prossimo vito
giocato ragazzi
[Musica]